check okay all right okay and they must
be tango tango I got to want you know I
got somebody for you yeah okay who you
like a challenge
you can bring whoever you want to bring
I'm ready for wealthy one car car hey
Mike it's Mario okay really from the car
I got somebody for you he talks a lot of
trash named Julian you know
[Music]
yeah what's taking so long Mario right
the people can't tell so here I am
young people are you serious I heard you
heard my friend now people's champ I
don't really hate that
no People's Champ I beat you you got
apologize right peoples Tara yes see
alright welcome to a blitz boning
special edition gangsta edition alright
so if he beats me
it's a hundred I've you here with me a
hunter he apologized our ears don't give
me hot you got it ya hear what you got
it come on little move holy moly
don't fall
and I'm like we gotta let you see them
anyway we love it I do a couple I might
pick up on drove into the knowledge I
might just taken a coupon I'm writers I
know I know
oh well I won't be in trouble I will be
trying to help you out every two people
chap I are you serious Mario some other
people's ten sister here I do something
that down
you win a prize will never play chess
again
terrible is it how you handle that right
Kurt Kurt come on people like what my
bishop you want it you want it you want
a little token all right well here's a
chance okay and you really doing some I
don't think they pulled are proven and
cathlin and an endgame don't know
nothing about himself
the peoples champ
Mario you got to beat it to my people
step I'm telling people tell this
through em look at me I think he'll
knows it though I know what to do what
you serious
you'll not leave people step I'm going
to do it right now
People's Champ are you have talked to
people bet it means the 'center
is horrible the people's taste I want to
shut you up
okay now going all the way up here okay
although I'll leave it on another dumb
yeah good one Ellen
that's why though he's gonna hurt violet
won't go there
here we go
yes
don't sir go you're going to get you're
going to get the next clock and liking
his it's going to get stuck y'all nobody
to blame but yourself people I want it
fair
oh yeah you did take that
oh the case Peter stop watching i just
trying to yeah you cannot explain that's
free three of them
Haymitch real
I'll have to check take them off on the
beepers tap would you like 89 first the
wrong you ain't wrong people stick man
kind of start one all right no more mr.
nice guy
okay look at look look look at that look
at that alright it's like a point your
palms okay
come again sometime big mistake very
mistake melody any big snake
what ask them what I do that twice you
play long enough you've gone about come
on
Latin don't want ya take your free any
stop you're free it up pre-med now it's
Sultan if I miss I miss I miss the shot
right thank you guys look at this shut
when I got this far and it's a People's
Champ take it all take it all and if
people said how much do something else
what
I'll take it all I'll take it all Hank
he will step through an event or watch
it yeah I got to get up feel you're
taking that d-file oh yeah
at the mark
oh and when people tell me that that's
why on the people camp that means right
there I'm gonna just go back again and
I'll see the people's change and you got
to stop Oh God I will avoid it I will
put welcome to like take perhaps even a
motorist tempted state I stay there that
Kobe Oh bleep let's trade the book let's
trade them up trade them up now is yummy
light of the fire
I got it
could be a lot of field
Panama's you want to be between us
Yayoi I've got it in the bag what's
telling you we've nothing to win at all
he was tapping huh
come on people statue and also active
the master the man and shopping I'm
trying to get over it and all your
friends let's go people
alright your straighten one of them okay
buddy which one which one your fish up
or you're not which one okay I'm just
calling and they say if you look on the
shot you get a day file now would comes
over in that word when do you doing any
holiday you laughing Bob what do you do
a little do I help them okay come on
wait let's go people stand unite them
come on people sent let's go
still people share an array we got a
level I could go check on them get right
here
all right well here come oh what's that
oh you're gonna think you're gonna see
you're gonna do next step
yeah you can step up come on there we go
here we go come on people
here we go no that's it
that's as if you don't get one get one
too you ain't in Oh Jeff and other Chuck
is on the way
come on come on what the right way you
want the right way up I'll give you
credit there yeah Oh Oh did not want to
go there
here I come here I come
you're right Oh Ellen I want to hurt
that one hurt yeah there you have that
you can have that I'm doing the good one
so there we go that's it
oh you guys we just run out of time
cause you are about to get cooked
apologize tomorrow I'm apologizing Mario
here Braun Mario he's a bum another
sighs now quit about - he's a bum
[Applause]